frauen werden in vielen
religionsgemeinschaften nach wie vor
benachteiligt männer haben das sagen
der unmut der frauen nimmt zu unter dem
motto für eine kirche mit den frauen ist
beispielsweise in den letzten wochen
eine gruppe von römisch katholischen
frauen und männern von der schweiz aus
zu fuß nach rom gepilgert
wir stellen die frage emanzipiert und
religiös wie geht das zusammen
wir das sind kathleen straub römisch
katholische theologin
sie möchte priesterin werden in ihrer
kirche das ist moment unmöglich sie
lässt sich aber mit billigen antworten
da nicht abspeisen
miriam heimann sie ist juristin und
yogalehrerin sie ist in der jüdischen
tradition verwurzelt die antwort von den
religionen von ihrer religion
da kriegt sie antworten auf
existenzielle fragen in ihrem leben war
starb wie ist das für viele menschen ist
der religion etwas veraltet dass etwas
aus der mottenkiste etwas uncool es wie
erleben sie das sie möchten priester
werden in der katholischen kirche ist
das nicht ein kampf gegen windmühlen
es ist natürlich schon ein kampf in
gewissen grad weil die kirche sagt als
frau kann ich einfach keine priesterin
werden
aber für mich als frau ist einfach die
katholische kirche heimat ich fühle mich
da auch sehr geborgen
und ich glaube es lohnt sich diesen
kampf auch auf sich zu nehmen weil wenn
man was ändern will dann muss man sich
auch dafür einsetzen und so das
kämpferische boxen ist ihr hobby hatten
sie da die energie oder ja von bozen die
kann mich auf jeden fall die energie
also ist auch mein ausgleiches boxen
widerspiegelt auch so ein bisschen mein
leben ich meine boxen da kann man nicht
einmal ins training gehen und dann
denken jetzt werde ich der große
weltmeister und trägt alle titel sondern
man muss viel viel und lange trainieren
man muss sehr viel ausdauer man muss
auch an sich arbeiten und so ist eine
kirche auch wenn man etwas verändern
will und ich will priesterin werden dann
muss ich dafür was tun dass ich eines
tages was ändert der katholischen kirche
aber es schon erstaunlich man spürt bei
ihnen keinerlei gegensatz zwischen
jungen demonstrierend und religiös es
ist ja auch kein gegensatz also man kann
heute jung sein kann auch weiblich sein
und trotzdem voll und ganz klar
in der jeweiligen religion aufgeben das
ist absolut kein widerspruch ist indes
für sicherheit machen wie erleben sie so
in ihrem umfeld die religion schon sehr
unterschiedlich ich hatte das glück in
meiner teenager jahren mit einem herren
rabbiner goldberger zu lernen als leider
verstorben vor ein paar jahren der mich
genau da abgeholt hat in meinem jungen
seien in diesem ganz aktuellen fragen
von wirklich um mit meinem dauer sein
und in meiner existenz in dieser
komplizierten welt und hat mir so auch
die tische religion näher gebracht und
sehr aktuell gemacht aber ich muss schon
sagen dass ich glaube dass dort ein
potenzial ist im judentum dass noch mehr
ausgeschöpft werden könnte um es
wirklich relevant zu machen
für die jungen leute also dieser
rabbinat offenbar das verstanden junge
menschen mit dieser religion ins
gespräch zu bringen
für viele ist einfach christentum auch
judentum so verbunden mit alten männern
die das sagen und wir erleben sie wenn
das gilt schon jetzt sehr viel
bestrebungen dies zu ändern und auch die
jüdischen gemeinden hat in amerika und
in israel dort läuft schon sehr viel
mehr noch wie in der schweiz
und ich würde auch sagen es ist immer
noch so dass es schon viele männer gibt
die dominieren aber ich würde auch ein
aufbruch und das macht auch mut und sie
gab es gibt doch auch eine große chance
sie würden sagen ich bin religiös das
ist auch eine schwierige frage
ich bin nicht praktizierend ich hatte
nicht das diesen ruhetag und ich esse
auch normal zu hause aber ich bin doch
irgendwo durch ein religiöser mensch und
das judentum jüdische religion die liegt
mir sehr am herzen und ich möchte auch
daran teilhaben
das muss natürlich um das zu verstehen
auch sagen dass es da ganz verschiedene
schattierungen gibt oder wie auch bei
den christen gibt es verschiedene
konfessionen es gibt auch in der römisch
katholischen kirche gibt es ganz
verschiedene fraktionen also je nach
standpunkt sind sie natürlich jetzt von
ganz streng orthodoxe seite vielleicht
nicht religiös von anderer seite sind
sie vielleicht religiös
wenn sie ihre kinder religiös ihre
töchter ja ich hab sie sich wirklich was
sie werden nach den jüdischen
kindergarten gehen
beim versuch in die feste näher zu
bringen und vielleicht ja doch würde ich
schon sagen ich hab da ein papst
franziskus auf ihrem handy entdeckt mit
der kirche sind sie sehr verbunden wie
anzieht denn sonst so religiös
sozialisiert sind sie da sehr
konservativ aufgewachsen oder gar nicht
also ich bin zwar eine sehr christlichen
dorf aufgewachsen alle waren waren
katholisch dartmann ging im religions-
bericht genau aber daheim man hat
natürlich die die feiertage praktiziert
also weihnachten ostern und auch die
adventszeit war muss er schon als kind
aber es war nicht so dass wir jetzt nach
beim essen beten würden oder dass wir
jetzt jeden sonntag in die kirche
gegangen sind also waren habe ich nur
einmal einmal in der woche ein mal im
monat einmal im jahr also an weihnachten
war mir eigentlich nur leckere meinen
glauben und auch meine liebe zur
katholischen kirche habe ich dann immer
eine jugend doch eine freundin und durch
ein cluster karten klassenkameraden
gefunden ist so ein richtiges
erweckungserlebnis oder so zu sagen ja
ich glaube wenn wenn junge menschen
wirklich noch gläubig sind dann können
sie auch auf andere jungen menschen
wirken
ich glaube die können sehr großes
vorbild sein auch für andere für andere
gleichaltrigen und bei mir hat es ja
gewirkt also meine freundin hab ich das
ja geprägt und durch sie wie ich sehr
dankbar wäre doch sie habe ich auch die
berufung zur priesterin gekommen
sag mal gesagt haben wir einen
rosenkranz die also bild sieht das dann
wirklich ja wenn ich kein großen kranz
dabei habe das bedürfnis hat dann nehme
ich dann durchaus mal handy in die hand
weil es ist sag mal was modernes und man
kann ja auch gleich mal traditionelle
elemente die wir eine kirche haben kann
man ja auch moderne umgestalten zum
beispiel rosenkranz oder auch die bibel
die offen auf einem handy ist in ihrem
boxclub wird sagt michael herrmann wer
ist das eher darauf oder das ist doch
der ich glaub ich glaube ich glaube
papst franziskus kennt man schon
ich glaube das ist wenn sie dann sagen
ich bin religiös übrigens oder so ich
weiß ja also viele zeigt natürlich was
tut glaubt an gott oder du gehst noch
eine kirche es wird natürlich schon sehr
wie sie vorhin gesagt haben mit alten
männer und identifiziert vor allem auch
dass die katholische kirche aber ich
sage
ich bin noch das beste beispiel dass man
jungs sein kann und trotzdem auch in die
kirche gehen kann und auch stolz drauf
sein kann und das beeindruckt die
dadurch aus dass ich im prinzip auch so
starkem einem blauen bin und in meiner
überzeugung dass die katholische kirche
meine heimat ist und da muss ich mich
keine dummen kommentare anhören zumal
sehr viele boxer auch sehr gläubige
christen sind erstaunlich ich hab mir
vorgenommen dass wir auch über die rolle
von frauen in den institutionen aus in
der katholischen kirche über judentum
sprechen haben wir einen kurzen
filmbeitrag vorbereitet über männer und
frauen die derzeit eben gardinen rom
ankommen
eine gruppe von römisch katholischen
frauen und männern hat sich von st
gallen aus im mai in diesem jahr auf den
weg nach rom gemacht
1000 kilometer zu fuß ihre forderungen
für eine kirche mit den frauen haben sie
an diesem wochenende papst franziskus
und arbeitet als staub unterstützen sie
diese gruppe auf jeden fall also es ist
wirklich es ist toll dass die frauen und
männer gemeinsam nach rom pilgern dass
sie ein zeichen setzen und zu sagen ja
wir setzen uns ein für eine dialogische
kirche für eine kirche mit den frauen
und es ist großartig und es mal schauen
was dabei rauskommt und wie das dann
auch im vatikan angenommen wird und
jetzt sagen sie naja priesterin das ist
es vielleicht nicht die erste forderung
von dieser gruppe aber für mich ist das
klar
aber da muss ich schon sagen da gibt es
im kirchenrecht der römisch katholische
kirche den satz kein 1024 dass sie
wissen schon was aus den kirchen
rechnerin ich habe vor wenigen tagen ihr
studium abgeschlossen
rc gratulation die heilige mai empfängt
gültig nur ein getaufter man meint sie
kennst doch etwas steht ja war das steht
da an das ist auch eine diskriminierung
bei es steht auch in cannes und 208 wenn
man schon mal ein kirchenrechts hin dass
eine wahre gleichheit zwischen allen
gläubigen gibt und ich glaube auch dass
wir doch die taufe gleich sind also
gleichwertig frau gott und darum ist es
eine grobe diskriminierung wenn eine
frau nur weil sie frau ist von ihrer
zeit mal von der berufung
ausgeschlossen dass es ihre berufung
nicht leben kann sie bringen das
argument der gleichberechtigung ein
zuschauer schreibt uns die wichtigsten
gründe für das priestertum nur für
männer sind jesus christus hat zwölf
männerberufen wer wollte da stimmt aber
jesus hat zwölf jüdische männerberufen
drei kriterien die alle drei einig
beachtet werden müssen und der zwölf
kreis wurde dann schon bald nicht mehr
eingehalten wir haben ja heute mehr als
nur zwölf bischöfe wir haben heute keine
jüdischen priester mehr also die zuvor
erst im judentum verankert waren und
dann zum christentum konvertiert sind
das heißt dieses argument der zwölf
kreis natürlich jesus hat zwölf männer
berufen aber es ist ein symbol das ist
ein zeichen für das volk israel die
zwölf stämme israels dass auch jeder
damals wusste er um die um jesus herum
war aha ist zu uns juden gesandt und das
ist das wichtige
und wir haben jetzt ja auch gesehen dass
maria magdalena ist ja auch zu aposteln
als einmal aufgestiegen
franziskus hat es vor wenigen tagen
verkündet jedenfalls liturgisch genau
aber die frau hat von anfang an wenn man
das neue testament aufmerksam liest von
anfang an haben die frauen wichtige
rollen gespielt und waren auf ein anfang
an mit dabei und jesus hat sie gleich
behandelt wie auch die männer
sie argumentieren natürlich auch mit der
tradition die sich verändert wenn sie so
zu hören wie kommt wie ihm das vor ich
meinen judentum gibt rabbinerinnen sind
die akzeptiert ja es kommt darauf an wo
acht arbeiter ultra orthodoxie in den
chaotischen so genannten kreisen die
sieht man auf der straße die mit den
hüten die man so gut von außen kennt ist
es nicht akzeptiert und ihr prinz einen
großen kreis nachschauen aber sind auch
interessant weil ich sie auch bei uns
ist es oft nicht mal ein problem von
religiöser nicht religiös sondern
einfach von traditionellen und modernen
also zum beispiel dauert die große
synagoge in zürich für die frauen oben
auf der empore und sozusagen zuschauer
am gottesdienst religiös wäre es absolut
kein problem dass die frauen auch unten
sind neben den männern aber doch so
viele leute wenigen die synagoge gehen
sind sie nostalgisch und wollen dass das
so ist wie schon immer war
der großvater und die großmutter und das
ist es ist kein religiöses problem
eigentlich sondern vielleicht die angst
vor veränderung die wir ja auch sonst in
der schweiz kennen
das bringt so die abwechselnd mit
bestehen bei navis für die anwesenden
dann ist es geht an den großen teilen
ich bin immer großen einheitsgemeinde es
gibt noch eine liberale gemeinde und die
ultra orthodoxe und gibt diese große
einheitsgemeinde wo gemischt ist und die
meisten juden juden von verschiedenen
richtungen wenn man sorgen zusammen mit
den meisten leben wahrscheinlich
religiös bin ich mir ziemlich sicher
aber doch noch
es geht doch einen starken hang zur
tradition und auch sie hat auch unter
druck studiums also um das erlebbar zu
machen wir haben kurzen ausschnitt
vorbereitet und das sieht aus einem
gottesdienst zur anuga in der synagoge
der israelitischen kultusgemeinde in
zürich vom dezember 2012
ml
ola
nein
eindrücklicher gesang was lebt ihn
ebenso auf ein gefühl von zuhause ich
gehe da einen aus meiner kindheit
ich gehe nicht so viel und ich führe
schon also ich gehe zu den religiösen in
das religiöse gebet haus weil ich es mir
zu sehen ein zuschauer gottesdienst
nicht nur wegen der frauen sondern auch
eigenen co im sommer toben die fahren
unten die männer aber sind die frauen
dran beteiligt sind zuschauerin in ihrer
sicht genau aber ich mein beten könnten
sie auch oben genau und ich gehe auch
aber ich habe also bei den noch
religiösen sind die frauen sogar hinten
aber auch unten
aber da ganz viele komponenten nicht nur
die fragen der emanzipation sondern auch
sonst für mich ist es wichtig ein
gefühlvoller gottesdienst viel gesungen
wird und da gehe ich dann lieber zu den
noch älteren und was erleben sie da es
ist einfach ein teil 1 teil haben und
ich bin schon das bedürfnis auch habe
noch nach einer gewissen sinnlichkeit
und das judentum ich war in den letzten
jahrhunderten schon sehr intellektuell
geprägt außer sich dieses gesetzes
religion und dann eben daran dass ihre
reguläre kulturelle geschichtliche
judentum und dass das sinnliche
mystische das ist ein bisschen ganz
kleinen kreis vorbehalten und ich auch
dieses tiefe bedürfnis biologielehrerin
und sehr viele menschen das ist ja immer
stark und haben dieses bedürfnis
irgendwie noch auseinandersetzung und
sinnlichkeit und und irgendwie fragen
von mit dieser diesem zwischen geburt
und tod stehen
was kann ich mich wenden
liegen diese werkzeuge die diese
sinnliche das habe ich dann gut abgeholt
da sind gar nicht nur fragen der
emanzipation sondern auch einfach wo
kann ich mich identifizieren als
interessant sie öffnet jetzt sozusagen
die tür hin zu einer anderen art von
spiritualität die im judentum zu hause
ist für sie scheint jetzt so eine frage
im ich will rabbinerin wird nein sie
sind yoga lehrer sie gar nicht so im
vordergrund
aber ich das richtig also ich glaube was
ich mich schon einsetzt nicht bin nicht
so solche großen ambitionen aber dass
ich wünsche mir eigentlich von meiner
gemein aber für das hätte ich mich auch
ein ist das ganz vieles verschiedenes
möglich ist sozusagen ein pluralismus
also nicht dass wir alle im gleichen
gottesdienst haben wo zb egalitär ist
sondern was einfach vieles möglich ist
wenn ich das gefühl habe dass ich sehr
profitiere von leuten die auf der dr
leben wie ich aber ich habe auch die
hoffnung dass auch sie inspiriert werden
von von leuten die etwas anders auslegen
und dass dieses nebeneinander existieren
kann in der vielfalt mit gegenseitigem
respekt und wertschätzung dass wir
dieses yoga sie praktizieren das sie
lehren das sehr intensiv das ist nicht
eine ausflucht er momentan ist
komplementär würde ich sagen also
irgendetwas reichert meinte sein
judentum und es gibt auch viele themen
wo ich als ich gelernt habe mit diesem
hobby nagold die sich überschneiden
also die eigentlich auch diese inhalte
die ich im yoga unterrichte und selber
lernen die die vereint werden können
und ich hoffe schon an ich glaube da das
potenzial besteht dass das noch mehr
ausgeschöpft werden kennt der innerhalb
der jüdischen gemeinschaft also wenn er
auf die inspiration aus dem yoga für
ihre jüdischen wurzeln
ich glaube das ist es im jüngsten selbst
auch gibt
ich glaube nicht dass ich das von außen
rein bringen muss aber weil es ein
bisschen spärlich ist zumindest in der
schweiz bin schon noch auf das yoga
angewiesen
das wäre dann etwas was die fahrer noch
mehr ansprechen würde im judentum
ich glaube alle
sie wollen ja nicht nur jetzt priestern
werden sie wollen auch gleich das
zölibat abschaffen da gibt es ja auch
einen kanon die kirchenrechtler in die
kleriker sind gehalten vollkommene und
immerwährenden tauglichkeit um des
himmelreiches willen zu wahren
deshalb sind sie zum zölibat
verpflichtet ich habe meinen freund was
ich wohl mal für familie gründen
sie haben sich schon ein bisschen viel
vorgenommen ich studiert theologie hre
hat theologie studiert und ich weiß wie
sich kirche entwickelt und bei dem thema
zölibat steht eigentlich nichts im weg
das zu ändern als zölibat ist auch
richtig offiziell erst zwölften
jahrhundert eingeführt worden es hat
sich auch geschichtlich entwickelt es
gab auch teilweise noch gibt es auch
dokumente die sagen das sogar bis ins 16
17 jahrhundert dass priester noch gar
nie verheiratet waren die sich nicht an
diese entscheidung gehalten haben und
wären wir dann zur tat aufheben dann
können wir zum beispiel das orthodoxe
modell namens wir würden da auch ein
bisschen bessere ökumene betreiben indem
wir sagen
diakone und priester dürfen heiraten und
die bischöfe dessen unverheiratete
männer die zum beispiel aus dem orden
stand com oder einfach nicht heiraten
wollten
und da aber die frauenfrage einfach eine
knifflige angelegenheit ist die vielmehr
diskussion bedarf wird zuerst der
zölibat fallen oder der pflicht zur
warte wir jetzt haben wozu einem zu
einem lockeren so lieber das im prinzip
nicht alle müssen heiraten sondern jeder
kann sich selber entscheiden und die
frauenfrage wird dann vermutlich als
zweites obwohl die frauenfrage
eigentlich jetzt auch schon diskutiert
werden muss aber sie braucht einfach ein
bisschen länger
ich bin wirklich erstaunt ich beobachte
diese diskussion seit ich sage jetzt
gerade jahrzehnten kommen junge frauen
daher und sagen so machen wir es jetzt
haben sie nicht den eindruck dass dieser
laden dann auseinander bricht man die
römisch katholische kirche hat auch
konservative flügel die dann sagen
das wären dann haben wir nichts mehr zu
tun aber man muss die leute einfach
überzeugen man muss überzeugen dass es
wichtig ist dass auch frauen ihre ihre
berufung leben dürfen dass priester die
verheiratet sind genauso gleich gute
priester sind wie wenn sie unverheiratet
werden man muss es denen einfach
argumentativ auch zeigen
und es gibt ja
viele gemeinden auch hier in der schweiz
wo frauen oder verheiratete männer soll
ein extrem viel in sachen machen also im
gottesdienst und auch dort eine große
bereicherung sind für die kirche und ich
glaube das wird sich nach und nach ein
bürgern des kurses problem ist dass
andere länder noch nicht bereits dass es
auch in den anderen kulturellen
kontexten die frau enorm gleich mal
herabgewürdigt wird und dementsprechend
dann auch gleich mal von der kulturellen
seite wenn jetzt die türe sagen würde
okay wir führen jetzt in afrika das
frauenpriestertum ein dort es durchaus
zur irritation kommen würde aber ich
glaube wenn man jetzt den dialog auch
ernsthaft beginnt kann man auch wirklich
sagen dass wir in ein zwei jahrzehnten
auch zum ziel kommen
vielleicht ist die frau die weniger
nichts einwand hat recht es nicht an
genau ich glaube das ist eher dass der
punkt wo ich viele frauen fühlen sich
fühlen sich benachteiligt fühlen sich
diskriminiert fühlen sich auch nicht
ernst genommen in der kirche in ihren
sein also weil sie ihren frau sind und
gerade die jüngere generation die damit
zeichnet die die jungen mädchen die mit
emanzipation und mit mit gleichen
rechten aufgewachsen sind die so erzogen
wurden für dieses natürlich ein anstoß
dann in eine in eine religion zu gehen
in der eben die frauen nicht die
gleichen rechte haben und damit religion
effektiv ist
das werden wir auch zeitgemäß sein weil
sonst ist es nicht gelebt ja sonst sind
es nur irgendwie die formen der
tradition aber tradition hat sich ja
immer entwickelt tradition ist immer
weitergegangen im youtube ist es ja auch
so also wissen sie und tom ist heute
nicht an einem punkt wo es vor 2000
jahren war und so ist im christentum
auch mit der katholischen kirche auch
die entwickelt sich weiter und wie so
schön man auf dem zweiten vatikanischen
konzil gesagt hat die zeichen der zeit
hören und auch nach den handel und das
müssen wir auch heute was die
frauenfrage anbelangt wenn sie so
zugehört haben bei der frage um die
spiritualität verstarb haben sie den
eindruck es geht bei ihm letztlich auch
darum oder wollen sie eigentlich lässt
sich ein anliegen durch stirn seine
berufung sag ich mal durchsetzen und das
ist natürlich ein spiritueller punkt
also ich hab mich da auch sehr gefunden
weil die berufung leben ist ja nicht ein
beruf ist ja kein job den man einfach
mal acht stunden am tag macht sondern
berufung bedeutet 24 stunden 7
tage die woche da sein und genau das
machen wenn ich sage ich möchte den
priesterlichen dienst ausführen für die
menschen und für gott und das ist
natürlich auch eine sehr spirituelle
ebene aber die kann ich nicht erreichen
weil ich eben frau bin die religion sind
papiere geprägt in denen sie
aufgewachsen sind von ihrer geschichte
her so wenn wir noch auf die
gottesbilder schauen was das haben sie
dafür für einen bezug mit all diesen
männlich besetzten gottes bildern
es gibt gibt es kein männlich geprägt
dass gottes wählt also finde ich schon
wichtig das ist auch mir zu wenig
wichtig dass sein dass man sich man darf
sich eben wirklich kein bündnis an gut
machen und das ist so stark ausgeprägt
das verbot dass es darum auch in den
synagogen keine bilder gibt und dass die
wir natürlich diesen spielraum
das dass ich frei bin was ich mir unter
gut vorstellen kann und dass es da ganz
viele verschiedene möglichkeiten gibt
und was stellen sie sich vor das war
keine frage die wir damals mit einem in
diesem rabbiner besprochen haben sich
jugendliche haben ihm gesagt als
irgendwie dieses beten das fällt uns
wahnsinnig schwer
die kindlich und abergläubig kann nicht
irgendein papier oder me wie meine
sachen vorlegen und dann haben wir
gemeinsam er mir das irgendwie ein gutes
bild das uns gefällt dass das sein
könnte irgendeine essenz die in allem
ist und irgendwie alle menschen gleich
unendlich wertvoll macht um denke dieses
wundersame der welt ist und danach ein
rabbiner gesagt ja und jetzt wenn es das
ist dann kann es vielleicht auch an
gegenüber sein was events dieser essenz
und alles ist dann ist es vielleicht
auch ein gegenüber wo man hin beten kann
und manchmal brauchen wir menschen nicht
so dieses abstrakte gerade wenn wir
aufgeholt sind sondern brachen wir reden
konkretes und da hat er mir wie eine
brücke gegeben dass
aktuell mit mir zu vereinbaren dass ich
beten darf oder dass versuchen kann
bringt sehr befreit oder ich meine das
vater unser zentrales gebet in der
christlichen tradition kommt ihm das
einfach über die liegt mir kommt es
einfach überlebten jahr werde ich also
ich wenn ich persönlich auch petit sage
ich auch immer du vater du mein vater
aber für mich ist das nicht ein
ein starres ähnliches bild sondern wenn
man wenn man aufmerksam die bibel es
waren auch das alte testament wird dort
auch immer mit weiblichen zügen gezeigt
also auch mit seiner mit mehr weiblichen
zügen als mit männlichen und gott ist
für mich einfach gottes
ich nenne ihn vater damit ich ein
begriff habe aber ich stelle mir nicht
als ein eine herrschender man vor das
auf keinen fall so weiblich aus pécs
michaelis fürsorgende oder auch die die
brütende henne die sich um ihre also
sagt dann auch jesus schon die sich um
ihre küken kümmert natürlich auch das
liebevolle das dasein
das sind solche dinge und ich glaube das
ist das was ich auch im leben immer
meinen persönlichen glaubens spür ich
spüre gott ist da gott ist barmherzig
gottes liebevoll und ja gut steht mir
zur seite
aber da ist keine spaltung drin oder
zwischen eben arbeiten die die hände
oder die andere tiere nein das sind ja
ich meine wir gerade schon gesagt gott
kann man ja nicht auf einem bild
fixieren aber man kann viele einzelnen
bildern zb gott der gute hirte ist ja
auch so ein bild ist dass er sehr
geläufig ist
die menschen damals haben wir auch
versucht gott irgendwie darzustellen und
zu sagen okay wie können wir ihn
beschreiben das heißt ich glaube es gibt
eine eine vielfalt von bildern die wir
gott als mir gott nennen können
vermutlich ist jedes bild richtig wenn
es dann auch für einen stimmt wir sehr
offen erzählt über ihren weg als junge
frau mit ihrer religion was man sie so
zum schluss dieses gespräch sagen was
ist für sie als frau in ihrer religion
was ist ihnen wichtig also mir ist
wichtig dass wir frauen genau gleiche
möglichkeiten haben wie auch die männer
und dass wir eben nicht abgetan werden
so von wegen
ihr als frau könnte auch schon viel
machen seit damit zufrieden ist und dass
wir wirklich auf unsere wurzeln schauen
als auf jesus christus wie er mit mit
den frauen und auch mit den männern
umgegangen ist und auch dementsprechend
handeln also ein bisschen zurück zu den
wurzeln und das dann auch ins heute
übertragen
mir ist es natürlich auch wichtig dass
wir die jugend wieder einfangen können
das weil ich meinen in 20 jahren wenn
ich hoffentlich priesterin bin will ich
nicht vor anderen lehrern
kirchengemeinde predigen betrifft ist
dass frau seien aber auch generell ich
möchte irgendwie authentisch sein und
mich einbringen genau so wie ich bin und
diese prozess fördern was auch andere
frauen den mut haben mit zu sprechen
weil ich glaube der prozess ist ein
wichtiger teil der emanzipation also sie
oft auch politisch wie ich gesagt habe
also dass wir aufstehen und zeigen den
mut haben zu sagen wenn wir singen und
der meinungsbildung teilzuhaben und eine
für eine generelle öffnung nicht nur der
frau gegenüber auch andere nicht der
partnerschaften sind themen oder
homosexualität als dass das eine
generelle öffnung platz hat und dass das
dann verbunden wird ganz natürlich mit
ihrer religion mit ihrer religiosität
ganz herzlichen dank für das gespräch
herr stratmann mit einem film über
boxende junge frauen geht es hier weiter
boxen ist für diese fahren wie ein
ventil macht sie selbstbewusster dem
steht auch die religion der frau nicht
im weg in den nächsten wochen zeigen wir
ihnen hier in den sternstunden in
unserem sommerprogramm perlen aus dem
archiv genießen sie den sommer